bonsoir claude blanche maison on vient
donc de l'entendre à la population qui
ne semble pas soulagé même que la
nomination récente d'un nouveau
gouvernement une équipe qui va
rapidement devoir prouver qu'elle est à
la hauteur cette fois si oui alors la
classe politique que les belges comme on
dit a mis 13 mois pour accoucher de ce
gouvernement il ya assurément des
contraintes l'accord de taef veut que le
premier ministre soit sunnite c'est le
cas mais en fait il ya eu d'autres
essais auparavant le président de la
république est un chrétien maronite et
le président de l'assemblée de
l'assemblée étant lui-même chiite mais
évidemment c'est pratique a été choisi
comme premier ministre mais par un
perdreau de l'année en réalité il a déjà
été premier ministre deux fois donc dans
une période de crise juste après
l'assassinât de rafic hariri c'est un
homme d'affaires à succès qui est
peillard d'air et qui a déjà été aussi
ministre des télécommunications au liban
alors il réunit les conditions dans le
fond parce que il connaît à la fois les
codes du milieu politique libanais et
les codes du fmi de la banque mondiale
de l'union européenne pour obtenir les
financements et les financements qui
pour le moment sont gelés et dans le
liban a cruellement besoin il a formé
une équipe de 24 ministres qui eux aussi
correspondent aux équilibre très délicat
entre les trois tendances religieuses
plus les druzes et c'est très délicat
parce que chacun veut avoir des
ministères très particulier en fonction
de l'accès qu'il donne au pouvoir à
l'influencé aussi à l'argent par
conséquent c'est pour ça que ça a pris
aussi longtemps pour former ce
gouvernement qu'il probablement est
aujourd'hui ce que la classe politique
libanaise compte tenu de ce qu'elle peut
produire de mieux avec un aspect
technocratique pour un certain nombre de
ministres même s'ils sont rattachés
chacun à une de ses filières religieuse
alors ses membres de cette équipe sont
tout de même un faut bien le dire accusé
d'être étroitement associé à la classe
politique corrompue pourtant ce
gouvernement né de la pression
internationale notamment française celle
d' emmanuel macron lui même ça veut dire
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément été entendu
ces français
je pense qu'encore une fois compte tenu
des contraintes de la politique
libanaise c'est ce qui pouvait être fait
de mieux sans révolution à lorient voilà
sans révolution dans l'état actuel des
choses et je pense que cette équipe va
en effet avoir à faire ses preuves alors
le premier test silva arrivé cette
semaine le milieu des finances a annoncé
qu'il déclenchait un audit de la banque
centrale libanaise et cet audit est
exigée par le fmi depuis longtemps pour
reprendre ses financements jusqu'à
présent il ya eu des tentatives diverses
pour avoir cet audit est à chaque fois
le gouverneur de la banque centrale a
refusé l'accès de ses bureaux et de ses
comptes au contrôleur donc on va voir ce
qui va se passer à la fin de la semaine
lorsque ou à la semaine prochaine
lorsque l'eau dite commencera mais c'est
un
un test très important et puis
naturellement ce gouvernement va devoir
s'attaquer à des réformes de structures
qui sont indispensables pour obtenir des
financements l'intérieur de l'union
européenne de la banque mondiale du fmi
est là et pas certain que cet équilibre
très fragile entre les diverses factions
permettent de faire les réformes de
structure qui devrait s'imposer alors
effectivement la population et
sceptiques et pensent que ce
gouvernement est issu de cette classe
politique assez largement corrompu et
n'aura pas là l'énergie politique pour
faire les réformes qui serait nécessaire
or la situation est catastrophique à
tous les égards hyper inflation chômage
massif les jeunes veulent partir bien
sûr les libanais qui ont de l'argent
sont partis depuis longtemps et le pays
est en train de sombrer de sombrer
également dans la dans la faillite et on
parle évidemment les exposants du port
de beyrouth qui a été un véritable
séisme sont le fonds humanitaire
également les proches un des victimes
attendent toujours des réponses il y à
même la demande d'une ouverture d'une
enquête internationale indépendante
clairement que peut on attendre de la
communauté internationale sur ce point
alors en effet il ya un premier juge
libanais qui a été nommé il a été
déchargé du dossier et qu'il a voulu
inculpé déjà important un deuxième l'a
remplacé et il est en train de lui
arriver la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sortent à l'inertie de la classe
politique en troisième lieu le parlement
refuse de lever l'immunité de l'immunité
parlementaire des députés de tous tel
tel ou tel député et par conséquent l
enquête nationale s'avère complètement
enlisé alors que le président à eaunes
ne veut pas d'enquêté internationale il
considère que ça serait tout à fait
contraire à l'indépendance du liban ce
serait une ingérence intolérable alors
il ya évidemment un précédent un peu
avec dans des conditions peut-être
encore plus dramatique lors de
l'assassinât
arcari
le secrétaire général de l'époque kofi
annan a déclenché une enquête
internationale mais il savait qu'il
avait l'appui du conseil de sécurité et
qu'il n'y avait pas de veto d'agde aucun
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
il a présenté ce rapport au conseil de
sécurité et le conseil de sécurité a
créé un tribunal international pour
juger les ceux qui avaient assassiné
tard était arrivé et effectivement la
situation n'est pas la même les
circonstances internationales ne sont
pas là même les mêmes non plus je pense
qu'aujourd'hui même s'il s'agissait de
l'assassinât d'un premier ministre il
n'y aurait pas d'unanimité au conseil
des mines et au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu pour créer une instance
internationale
par conséquent les ong ont 145 ong ont
donc sollicité
le conseil des droits de l'homme de
genève qui n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
qui peut évidemment discuter mais qui
pourra pas prendre de mesures actives
pour qu'il ne pourra pas agir sur une
enquête internationale alors il reste la
dernière solution c'est en effet de
faire pression en disant en négociant
avec ce gouvernement libanais la
présence d'experts d'autres pays à
l'intérieur de l'équipe d' enquêtes ça
m'est déjà été proposé par monsieur
macro d'ailleurs qui avait proposé les
experts spécialistes de ces sujets pour
débloquer l'anc est pour le moment c'est
pas possible à suivre donc merci que
gans maison merci d'avoir été avec nous